sabían que una vez un psicólogo ganó el
que es conocido como el premio nobel de
economía
han escuchado alguna vez muy bien he
escuchado alguna vez
el potencial que tiene la psicología y
otras ciencias sociales para contribuir
y ampliar los horizontes de la economía
algunos sigue alguno
[Música]
habían escuchado sobre esta nueva área
de esta área emergente que se llama
economía conductual o economía del
comportamiento
pues bien los invito a seguir esta
historia y a través de esta descubrir
alguna de las ideas está muy interesante
haría que mi pasión
para empezar quiero que todos tienen los
ojos
a ver cierra los y quiero que nos
remontemos al perú de algunas décadas
atrás digamos de fines de los ochentas
que escuchan que ven seguro muy bien
terrorismo descontentos sociales
protestas hiperinflación etcétera ahora
quiero que abran sus ojos
mírense entre ustedes el tiempo ha
pasado
vean centro ustedes y reflexionen que el
perú pese a los problemas que tenemos
porque los seguimos teniendo ha avanzado
hoy hay gente miren a mí que tenemos
metas tenemos sueños y no sólo eso sino
que hoy es posible alcanzarlos
pues bien cuando me planteaba que
estudiar yo quería algo que pudiera ser
aplicado para el desarrollo de mi país
entonces yo me preguntaba qué es lo que
podría estar detrás de los principales
problemas de una sociedad
y que hay en cuenta que quizás era la
economía la economía como base para
mejorar el bienestar de las personas
no obstante qué pasa si uno empieza a
percibir que esta economía no es tan
real y tan humana como uno inicialmente
creía
cuando uno estudia economía uno llega a
la clase de mi economía y la primera
cosa que le dicen son estos los
supuestos su axioma selección racional
de bolonia mambo reacción del 47 el
axioma de la completitud transitividad
continuidad independencia quiero
transmitirles la intuición de uno de
estos el de transitividad por ejemplo si
yo les pidiera elegir entre un plato de
vino naranja supongamos que la gran
mayoría prefiere el plátano y luego yo
les diera a contrastar entre una naranja
y una manzana supongamos que la gran
mayoría prefieren la naranja y yo les
labores hago la comparación entre
plátano y la manzana me van a decir que
van a preferir el plato
este ordenamiento de ideas estos axiomas
que nosotros suponemos justamente para
mover una gente racional que nos permite
pues nos permite
elaborar funciones es tener derivadas
considerar distribuciones crear modelos
matemáticos
eso es algo muy bueno para el economista
pero que pasa muchas veces nos hemos
sentido tentados un poco embelesados por
la gran elegancia de las matemáticas y
hemos tomado la realidad y la hemos
amoldado para que quepa en nuestros
modelos en vez de luchar para ampliar
nuestro conocimiento de las matemáticas
y podría explicar al menos un poco de la
gran complejidad que es el mundo y la
sociedad
en aquel tiempo a la universidad también
un momento para cocinar muchísimo por
los idiomas eran una ventana a nuevas
culturas cada uno de estos se prosiguen
en ese momento también que hay en cuenta
de otro detalle los economistas muchas
veces generalizamos hablamos en términos
agregados por ejemplo quizás son
ejemplos sacados de los pelos pero si
vieron extraterrestre y tuviera que
decidir nos a nosotros como seres
humanos podría decir que somos gentes
con dos piernas dos brazos una cabeza y
un testículo uno solo
en promedio
se dan cuenta que pasa cuando
generalizamos los economistas
obviamente controlamos por género por
sexo y muchas otras variables pero
siempre iban a haber variables que se
pierden variables que pueden ser muy
relevantes a nivel individual y el nivel
étnico y de grupos sociales etcétera
en aquel momento y mi pasión por los
idiomas alguna vez fuera de la
universidad encontré un anuncio que
decía se enseña lengua de señas y dije
bueno genial un nuevo idioma que
aprender un idioma que estudia que
estudia las señas pues genial fui y lo
que descubrí fue que no sólo esta
generalidad que hacemos a veces los
economistas puede tener un impacto en
nuestros modelos sino también cómo
percibimos y como finalmente diseñamos
políticas
la comunidad sorda es una comunidad de
millones de personas en el país pero que
suele permanecer invisible al punto de
que muchas de las personas de esta
comunidad sienten o ven en su vínculo
amical o sentimental con los oyentes
como uno de sus principales o su único
medio para poder obtener mayores
oportunidades y salir adelante cuando no
debería ser así
quiero plantearles este dilema dilema
del tranvía o dilema del tren planteado
inicialmente por la filósofa británica
fort en el 67 imagínense que ustedes ven
un tren un tren que pasa y en el camino
ese tren hay cinco personas atadas ahí
por algunos economistas malvado digamos
que no fui hacia atrás
y ustedes ven que su costado hay una
palanca con la cual pueden desviar el
tren pero al accionar la va a irse por
otra vía en la cual hay nuevamente una
persona atada por algún economista
malvado que recargo no fui yo
póngase a pensar en esa situación
quería
acción haría en la palanca o no
dejarían que mató cinco personas o la
acción harían para que vire mate una
verdaderamente cinco vidas valen cinco
veces una
qué complicado pues si además de ser
este un dilema moral de lema ético
también es un claro ejemplo de lo
complicado que suelen ser varias de
nuestras decisiones
fue dándome cuenta de estas cosas que
entendí que la economía no podía
explicar todo era difícil que puede
explicar varias de nuestro proceso de
toma de decisiones en ese entonces en la
universidad
tuve una muy buena amiga una compañera
que estudiaba psicología y que me
introdujo muchos de esos temas a partir
de ahí empecé a interesarme mucho por
esta conexión entre la economía y la
psicología que a veces no es tan
evidente
pero luego tuve la fortuna de formarme
especializarme en esta área y descubrir
una disciplina que justamente combina
estas dos ciencias sociales y se llama
la economía del comportamiento o
economía conductual
quiero que vean esta imagen muchos miran
marcos ya sé esas dos mesas son
exactamente del mismo tamaño del mismo
largo pues si no se trata de eso lo que
quiero que se den cuenta es que pese que
racionalmente saben que son del mismo
tamaño igual su cerebro lo va a hacer
ver le va a hacer creer y sentir que la
de la derecha es más larga que la de la
izquierda pese a que son exactamente del
mismo largo
ahora quiero que en estos dos círculos
yo he visto muchas veces por internet
que son exactamente iguales pero
recuerden que pese a que racionalmente
saben o yo les puedo decir que son
exactamente iguales
van a percibir al de la izquierda como
más grande que el de la derecha
pese a que como ya lo dije a le dije son
exactamente iguales
pues es esta misma intuición de las
ilusiones la que se puede también
entender en como nosotros nos desviamos
como tenemos sesgos en nuestro proceso
de toma de decisiones y uno de ellos es
conocido como efecto marco nada que ver
con mi nombre por cierto es nuestra
reducción al español del framing effects
estudiado por carne manifest y en el 81
imagínense que ustedes son ministros de
salud en una pequeña naciones y ciertas
personas y deben enfrentar una
enfermedad extranjera y sus científicos
le dan a elegir dos tipos de
medicamentos un medicamento con el cual
200 personas se salvarán
o un medicamento con el cual hay un
tercio de probabilidad que 600 personas
se salen y dos tercios que nadie se
salva
qué opción elegiría
veo un poco de duda ahí pero muchos
inclinan por la primera he escuchado
hace un poco más evidente veamos
nuevamente esa situación igual ministro
de salud de una pequeña nación decir las
personas una enfermedad extranjera qué
medicamento elegiría
opción de medicamento x 400 personas
mueren o medicamento y con el cual hay
un tercio de realidad que nadie muera y
dos tercios de probabilidad que 600
personas mueran que elegirían ahora
ahora hay un poco más de duda no hay
tanta inclinación por la equis por ahí
escucho un poco más del aire porque en
este experimento cuando se realizó en el
81 justamente yo los siguientes
resultados en el primer caso la gente
eligió en su gran mayoría la opción a
72%
y en el segundo caso sólo un 22 por 7
dije la opción x un 78 por ciento eligió
la opción
pero se han dado cuenta de algo la
opción es exactamente igual en la opción
x si yo les planteo países visitas
personas si doscientas se salvan cuántos
mueren 400 lo cual es la opción x hay x
son exactamente iguales así como veis
también lo son las opciones en concreto
no han cambiado lo único que se modificó
fue cómo se ofreció como se enmarcó la
respuesta y ese nuevo en marca miento a
ese cambio de plantearlo como una
ganancia como una pérdida tu impacto tan
significativo al punto de poder revertir
las preferencias de las personas
esto derivó en lo que se conoció como la
teoría de la prospectiva lo cual
justamente contribuyó a que daniel
kahneman psicólogo ganara el premio
nobel de economía en el 2002 este india
plantea sostenemos un punto de
referencia a partir del cual
consideramos las cosas como perdidas o
como ganancias además que el impacto de
las pérdidas es mucho mayor en nuestras
mentes que les su correspondiente
ganancia una pérdida de 100 soles tiene
un impacto mayor en nuestra mente es que
una ganancia decir
otra teoría muy interesante un pináculo
también de la economía el comportamiento
es la del descuento cuasi verbo lic o
descuento hiperbólico dirán que es este
nombre tan rimbombante bueno es el
nombre solo de una función pero quiero
dejarlos ustedes con la intuición
simplifiquemos pensamos que es medio día
y yo les ofrezco un slider pizza tienen
un slide de pizza ahora o quizás
prefieren dos slides pero aquí a tres
horas a las tres
mucho ustedes dijeron si al inicio un
slider pixar en este momento está bien
es válido
pero qué pasa si ahora yo le estaba
decidir
que prefieren un slider pizza de aquí a
un mes a esta hora
o dos es la dice pizzas de aquí a un mes
pero a las tres a las tres
muchos dirán bueno si voy a esperar un
mes entonces ahora mejores pero dos
meses y tres horas y media no sus lights
verdad
pues bien justo ahí también será una
reversión de preferencias algo que bajo
un descuento exponencial de la economía
tradicional no podría ser explicado
un nuevo ejemplo para que tiene la
intuición imagínense que ustedes llegan
viernes luego de estar súper cansados y
el siguiente sábado a las 11 tienen un
examen y ustedes se comprometen a otra
temprano para estudiar y la voy a hacer
cuántas veces han dicho eso la noche
previo la hago mucha verdad pero qué
pasa el nuevo
nos acercamos ya al más al momento en
que tomamos la decisión ya amaneció
suena la alarma a las 5 de la mañana
tienen que levantarse para estudiar
cuando ustedes no se han visto tentados
a apagar la alarma nada buenos
muchos verdad qué pasó ahí nuevamente
hubo una reversión de preferencias
conforme la el momento de toma de
decisión se acercó al presente
ustedes sufrieron este sesgo del
presente y la tentación de dormir un
rato más pese a que ese es un beneficio
de corto plazo y no algo tan promisorio
como dar un buen examen y tener un mejor
desempeño finalmente fue lo que impactó
de ustedes imagínense eso llevado a
otros contextos por ejemplo cuando a
veces se han visto tentados de algún
caramelo en vez de cuidar su salud
cuantas veces como sociedad vemos
tentados a seguir contaminando en vez de
preservar mejor el medio ambiente
interesantemente se ha ido descubriendo
que también la pobreza las limitaciones
económicas tienen un impacto psicológico
en las personas y precisamente es por
esta vía
yo estudié san marcos' una universidad
pública una universidad de la que me
siento realmente muy orgulloso y en la
cual confluye gente de todo tipo de
diversos económicos y gente muy pero muy
inteligente muchísimo más de lo que yo
seré
justo cuando yo estudiaba en algún
momento me gustaba preguntar a mis
compañeros y me di cuenta que aquellos
que lamentablemente tenían más
dificultades financieras por abe se
limitaban en algo en sus proyecciones
yo les decía oye bueno cuando en esos
que quieres ser que sean bueno conseguir
un trabajo y no había más y eso es
totalmente válido
pero aquellas personas y en general yo
les digo muchas veces dejamos de lado
en voz de beneficios quizás más tirados
al presente dejamos de lado beneficios
que serían mejores algo más al futuro es
verdad a veces tenemos que hacer algunos
sacrificios algunas inversiones pero
esos beneficios futuros que podemos
obtener por una mejor formación y un
mayor esfuerzo finalmente no sólo se van
a ver reflejados para nosotros sino
también para nuestras familias y en
general en nuestra contribución para
nuestra sociedad y nuestro país
entonces esta idea de tratar de empujar
un poco a la sociedad a la gente por el
camino correcto tiene un nombre se llama
un h es justo la definición planteada
por richard thaler el premio nobel de
economía del 2017
esta idea de cómo una madre elefante
empuja a su hijo pequeño por el buen
camino que también se usa en estas
herramientas dadas por la economía de
comportamiento para poder empujar a la
gente hacia toma decisiones más
adecuadas para su propio beneficio y
para el de la sociedad
quiero darles este ejemplo de donación
de órganos por un tema por johnson y
goldstein en el 2003 observe el
porcentaje de donadores órganos en cada
país y en el caso de alemán y el caso de
austria notan una gran diferencia 12% en
1 y 99% en otro que explica esto
diferencias culturales quizás
no parece no alemania austria son
relativamente parecidas culturalmente
hablando pues bien lo que está detrás de
todo esto es el formulario que se usa en
un primer caso en los primeros países en
rojo se usa un fular yo en el cual por
defecto como base la gente no es un
ahora de órganos salvo que indique lo
que quiere hacer
en el segundo caso todos son donadores
de órganos salvo que indiquen
que no quieren serlo y solo ese pequeño
cambio de la opción default de la opción
base puede tener un impacto muy
significativo en el porcentaje de
donantes efectivos que finalmente va a
tener un país
y les menciono este ejemplo por dos
cosas
les comenté esta compañera con la cual
empecé a interesarme por la psicología
ella falleció muy joven
falleció justamente por un aneurisma y
en su momento su familia
optó por hacer que pudiera donar sus
órganos
qué bonito verdad poder expandir una
vida a través de otras
y lo segundo que bonito sería usar esas
herramientas dadas por la economía del
comportamiento justamente para que esto
se pudiera extender hay tantas personas
en los hospitales esperando día a día
por algún donante y tampoco oferta de
donación de órganos que sería bueno
diseñar una política que contribuya a
esto
y ese es el segundo punto justamente
esta semana el ministerio de salud está
debatiendo este cambio cambiar la opción
default del no a que sea la opción
default del xi preservando siempre la
libre elección todos podemos ser o no
ser van de órganos de cuerda como
queramos pero finalmente un cambio en
esta primera opción puede tener un
impacto positivo e incluso salvar vidas
como ya han visto en este ejemplo
finalmente quiero darles unas pequeñas
perspectivas de la economía
comportamiento en un futuro como ya
hemos visto esto de las neurociencias
cada vez entendemos más cómo funciona
nuestro circuito de toma de decisiones
así también entendemos cómo es que
valoramos ya hemos identificado las
partes las zonas de nuestro cerebro que
se comprometen en este proceso poco a
poco así podemos ir e ir más allá de lo
que alguna vez dijo un economista como
milton friedman esto de que los modelos
económicos sólo deben ser juzgados por
su capacidad predictiva más no por la
veracidad de sus supuestos ni sus
axiomas quizá si es momento de ir más
allá de eso y realmente las bases que se
ubican en el cerebro de nuestro proceso
de toma de acciones para entender de
forma más precisa qué es lo que pasa
dentro de cada uno de nosotros qué es lo
que pasa en nuestras cajas negras
así también hoy vivimos en una época de
datos verdad día a día se generan más
datos en facebook en google en twitter
en youtube etcétera y muchos de sus
datos que son son datos sociales de
preferencias
de elecciones etcétera
todos esos datos que en conjunto
podríamos decirle que son un big data
social nos permitirán también tener un
mejor una mejor comprensión de cómo es
que la gente elige
y así poder crear una sí mismo más
específicos para poder tener un impacto
positivo en ámbitos de desarrollo pero
hay una podría decir marco esto puede
estar también un poco peligroso si se
usa de mala manera y es verdad puede ser
un poco peligroso si se usa para lo
cuestionable algún fin político quizás
algún fin en el cual no estemos todos
muy de acuerdo y es por eso que debemos
preservar siempre que el ámbito de
acción de los nats y de la economía del
comportamiento debe ser ámbitos de
desarrollo ámbitos como mejora educativa
como la reducción de pobreza la mejora
del medio ambiente de salud etcétera
ámbitos en los cuales todos estemos de
acuerdo y quiero aquí traer a colación
una frase del tío que te espera que
justamente siempre debemos recordar y es
que un gran poder conlleva siempre una
gran responsabilidad
finalmente
tanto del lado de un mejor entendimiento
de las personas en su capacidad en sus
emociones sus pasiones sus llantos y sus
risas como los hemos sentido hoy como
por el lado de su aplicación en ámbitos
de desarrollo en el cual todos estamos
de acuerdo
por esos razones es que yo denomino esta
área como una economía más humana
si bien se conoce comúnmente como la
economía conductual
alguna vez nuestro premio nobel vargas
llosa dijo que algunas veces los
economistas cuentan mejores historias
que los novelistas
lo dijo no sé si esta sea una de estas
veces pero humildemente espero que se
hayan quedado con algo hayan aprendido
todo sucede es algo y sepan utilizarlo
de la mejor manera muchas gracias
[Aplausos]